オーケー、それで先日
、
風刺的な日本のコンビニエンス ストアの
運搬ビデオのような 88 の YouTuber についての
ビデオをアップロードしました。そのビデオをアップロードした後、その YouTuber についてだけでなく
、胸から離れなければならないことが他にあることに気付きました。
率直に言って、日本に住んでいるほとんどの外国人は、日本に住んでいる外国人
の圧倒的
多数が、
日本人として十分に
振る舞っていないということです。
居住者であり、居住者で
あることには、言語を学ぶなどの特定の責任
が伴います。
日本語を話す人は
文字通り日本について文句を言うことは決してないことに気づいたこと
がありますか? 日本は
私のようにあなたは日本語を話す必要があり
ます いつでも外国人のように あなたが
日本に住んでいるなら日本語を話す必要があります
後で字幕をつけて
くれませんか。すみません、先日、ここで皮肉なことを見ていませんか？
私は友人と会話していました。
ええと、友人の 1 人にすぎません。それは本当の
会話でしたが、彼は
それがどれほど難しいかについて不平を言っていました。 日本語を学び、日本人が
いかに
英語を上手に話せないかを学び、私は
タカラ・ホン・ジンを見せてくれました。
見ている多くの人
が日本語をまだ完璧に話せていないことを知っている
ので、それは明らかに彼らが日本人だからです。
なぜ彼らはあなたの基準を正しく満たす必要があるのか
など、これは実際
にこのビデオの最後のポイントにつながり
ます. それならあなたはただの
迷惑だから、あなたは家に帰るべきです
あなたがいなくても日本は元気になるように
日本経済は
順調ですつまり、円は反発するということです。
これらはただ
の成長痛です。
いくつかあることを知って いわゆるアナリストが言ったように、
日本企業は十分な若者を見つけることができない
が、あなた
は渋谷や原宿に行ったことがあるようだ.
どこにでも若者がいる.若い人しかいない.
私たちは
アカマの擁護者を演じ
て、いわゆるアナリストが正しいふりを
することができます。日本企業の観点から物事を考えます。コードを知ら
ないが完璧な日本語を話せない人が欲しいですか、それとも
できる人が欲しいですか? コードは完璧ですが、
完璧な日本語を話します。私たちは皆、
その質問に対する答えを知っています。なぜなら、
これらは日本の企業であり、英語で
物事を説明できる人がいるだけでは
ないからです。
彼らにとって何が良いかについて これが理由です
外国人にとって最も重要なこと
は完璧な日本語を習得
すること
です